Lorraine Cink here at the world premiere
of Marvel Studios black panther we are
going to walk the purple carpet and show
you everything the celebrities are gonna
see and see who we catch up with from
the film let's check it out I'm here
with the ghetto film school and what
movie are you guys here to see what are
you excited to see tonight I'm excited
to see all these amazing actors come in
and do what they do if you were told me
when I was a kid but there was gonna be
a giant black panther movie I don't flip
my head it's great to see the character
have his day representation of black
culture and ethnicities and just coming
together and there's some badass females
and I just love when when comic book
movies get to go outside and create
these world it's a whole new chapter and
music also seems amazing yes and you
all-star cast full of Legends is really
it just looks super rad I can't wait
like I'm geeking out I was like get me
through the Glens like get my feet and
watched everyone perform ryan coogler is
amazing and I've been playing basketball
with Michael B Jordan since he was about
14 so that's true yeah yeah I used to
play with them a lot and Chadwicks
amazing so I just there's something that
feels special about this one I'm gonna
be like a little kid just watching all
of this black excellence on the screen
and Marvel imagine
I just I can't wait to see this many
like people of color and just beautiful
melanin everywhere and gorgeous thought
it's just like it's so stunning I've
been a black panther fan since I was a
little dick tonight I'm most excited
about the fact that there is a whole
planets of black and brown children who
are gonna get to see themselves
reflected in a superhero movie this is
nothing more exciting poor kid that was
your world premiere experience I'm gonna
go watch the film right now but you
should see Marvel Studios black panther
in theaters on February 16th
this is Marvel your universe